sons of the forest is finally here and
it kicks a significant amount of ass the
long-awaited follow-up to 2018's the
forest just hit Early Access and you may
be wondering if you should start playing
now or wait until the full release let's
answer that question in the most
spoiler-free way possible
sons of the forest is a co-op survival
horror game that tasks you with finding
and rescuing a high-profile family
trapped on a mysterious island your
helicopter crash lands at a random spot
and it's up to you to survive I've
started three different saves and each
time I've crash landed in very different
areas each with a unique setup in the
first save the helicopter got stuck in a
few trees the second time I landed in
the water just off the coast and the
third time I landed in the snow-capped
mountain in the dead center of the
island each crash had a unique Landing
scene that fit the region in the water
landing I'd kick open the chopper door
in the tree Landing I fell out of the
suspended copter and in the snow crash
the helicopter tumbled toward me
from there you need to gather any
supplies you can find and set up a
temporary or permanent shelter so far
compared to the original building and
crafting has changed the most while some
structures can still be built with the
translucent AR style blueprints sons of
the forest takes a more free-formed
approach to building once you've found a
suitable plot of land you can just start
splitting and placing logs to build a
floor then you can put down support
pillars and build walls building a roof
requires you to throw down beams and
struts before you start laying down
panels it's more complex this time
around but far more rewarding because
you are individually splitting and
placing each log until you've built
yourself a little home away from home
this makes your base feel handcrafted
and unique to you or your group specific
needs and tastes it can be a bit finicky
at times and I imagine building massive
multi-story complexes could get a little
tedious but it's impressive how
intuitive the whole system is once you
get the hang of it with your ax equipped
logs can be split in half and chopped
into smaller pieces depending on the
angle you're looking at it from to make
a spiked wall put a log into the ground
and look at the top of the log to
Fashion a spike to build a campfire hold
the stick and look down with the Press
of a button your character will snap the
stick in two and start a fire like I
said it can be a little janky
particularly on uneven ground but most
of the time it works pretty well some
structures can also be built the old way
by placing a translucent blueprint and
feeding it the required materials even
with this building style though you
still need to invest resources in a
logical order this means that if a
treehouse requires 40 logs for the roof
and 20 planks for the floor you can't
dump the roof lugs into the structure
until you've invested all 20 planks the
UI doesn't always do a great job of
conveying that information early on but
once you know you know
the key ingredient to all of this though
is Kelvin Kelvin is your resourceful AI
companion that can do all sorts of
helpful things for you and your party he
can gather fish collect sticks and
follow you around basically whatever you
tell him to do he will do just that
until you tell him to stop I think he
does need to rest from time to time but
he will gladly catch you fish until the
sun explodes and the world ends now if
you've been following sons of the forest
these past few days you've probably seen
that Kelvin can also chop down trees and
gather logs this is rad in theory but it
seems like our boy K can't determine
which trees you've built on and which
ones you haven't this means he could
destroy all your hard work with a few
swings of his ax
foreign
thankfully this hasn't happened to me
yet but if you tell them to gather logs
he will grab all the loose logs in the
area even the ones you are working with
it's annoying but we love Kelvin here
he's just trying his best and I'm sure
this is something that the team at n
Knight are looking into While You're
Building you'll also need to monitor
your hunger thirst and sleep these
meters are pretty easy to manage while
you're exploring the island there are a
ton of berries to forage animals to hunt
and meal kits to find thirst levels are
also pretty easy to maintain since
running water is safe to drink just set
up a camp near a stream and you should
have no trouble staying hydrated hunger
thirst and sleep plays a much bigger
role while exploring the cave system
here you'll want to be prepared and well
equipped some of these spelunking
Adventures can last multiple days
meaning you'll need to bring food
camping equipment and healing items the
cave Network in the original forest was
one of the highlights for me because I
felt so vulnerable one wrong turn and I
could lose track of my buddy and get
jumped by a pack of cannibals in the
dark I never knew what to expect and it
was always exciting to see where one
cave would lead and how it could connect
to another it's hard to say how
connected the caves are in Sons of the
forest at this point but they still
offer a decent serving of nightmare fuel
they are pitch black maze-like dungeons
filled with horrifying monsters that
will take you by surprise this one we
call fingers is the worst one I've seen
so far like I said some of these treks
can last a couple days so careful
resource management is key especially
since it's impossible to know exactly
how long any cave could be and where it
will spit you out so far the caves have
all been worth the effort I've explored
six caves four of which had new useful
equipment while the other two hinted at
some interesting story developments like
I said at the top I won't be getting
into spoilers but I am very excited to
explore more also every cave I've
checked out I found an incredibly useful
tool waiting for me at the end a rope
gun which is effectively a zip line that
can also be used to fairy logs a shovel
for digging obviously a diving suit for
exploring under water caves which is
still terrifying and some weapons and
attachments each item has had a
significant impact on either my combat
exploration or building capabilities
like the first game there's an engaging
Loop that consists of building prepping
and exploring in order to procure new
equipment that could allow you to
explore a new area or build more
elaborate structures the further you
travel from your base to explore more
caves the tougher it is to survive
meaning you need to be even more
prepared of course as you grow stronger
and more familiar with your surroundings
so do the cannibals the wall you build
might hold off some of the crawling foes
but eventually a big boy is going to
smash through your walls and wreck some
Havoc the melee combat for the most part
feels pretty similar to the forest there
are a handful of different melee weapons
and you can either do a light swing with
left Mouse click or a heavy swing by
holding it down most weapons can block
with right Mouse click overall it feels
more precise than the forest did but
it's still pretty straightforward attack
block and heavy attack all without
getting too close range combat has
received more of a revision due to the
introduction of firearms it seems there
are a handful of weapons that can be
found throughout the island but the only
one I found is the handgun ammo is
limited and the lack of crosshairs make
aiming intentionally difficult I want to
get Virginia a shotgun yeah
wow holy [__] his head came right the
[__] off I haven't used the gun too much
because I'm trying to conserve ammo but
lining up headshots can be really
satisfying weaker cannibals can be
eliminated with one well-placed shot
while tougher units might take a few now
even with the introduction of firearms
sons of the forest isn't a fast-paced
first-person shooter this is still a
survival game at heart and most of your
time will be spent foraging crafting and
exploring this could change later in the
game if ammo and guns become more
readily available but as of now it still
feels true to its roots okay now let's
address the elephant in the room does
this game Feel Like An Early Access game
a few weeks before launch developer end
night announced that sons of the forest
would be an early access title for folks
who had been following the game up to
launch this came as a surprise according
to the developer this was to prevent
another delay while they work out some
bugs fine-tune the balancing and add
some new game mechanics if all goes well
this early access period should last six
to eight months based on what I've
played so far sons of the forest feels
like a full release in scope but with
the amount of bugs and glitches you
might expect from an early access
release along with some of the weird
building issues I ran into I also
experienced floorboards that swallowed
up my fish whenever I tried to cook NPCs
floating a few visual glitches in the
crafting menu and some resources
mysteriously Vanishing probably one of
the weirder bugs I found so far is in
one multiplayer save I have with friends
our seasons are just out of sync all
right
so here it is it's winter for me and it
is raining
while three of us are experiencing a
harsh and beautiful winter he was
enjoying a wet and Breezy spring we
think this probably happened because our
hosts didn't start the game in the
default season and that kind of just
messed things up from there your
tolerance may vary when it comes to
these issues but apart from the
misaligned seasons I found the bugs to
be tolerable enough just to continue
playing on the gameplay side sons of the
forest is missing a large amount of
craftables that were present in the
original like the log sled and the
houseboat I will go through the entire
list but your options feel far more
limited this time around maybe some of
these blueprints I will find as I
progress but hopefully this is something
the team will expand on in the coming
updates additionally I hope we see more
UI settings in the future right now the
only two UI elements you can toggle are
the mini map and some crafting menu
stuff that means when you play
multiplayer your friends names will
appear over their heads this may not
bother some but but for me it kind of
robs the tension out of cave diving with
friends finally I hope the team adds
some form of proximity chat I love the
idea of having to rely on our
walkie-talkies to communicate if we get
separated in a cave but without
proximity chat it's a pain to constantly
bring out the walkie-talkie whenever I
want to communicate even if we're just
right next to each other sons of the
forest is still a bit rough around the
edges but it's shaping up to be a worthy
follow-up to one of my favorite survival
games of all time the Early Access
release definitely has a few hurdles but
as a package it doesn't seem to be
lacking in content there's plenty to do
to see and to build